[Musique]
il a une buse et si michel david
christian dufour bonsoir bonsoir alors
je les montre est plutôt la photo du
jour de cette campagne électorale 2000 $
qu'on veut redonner aux personnes âgées
non seulement c'est à peu près pareil
mais c'est la même journée à peu près la
même heure compromet ça
c'est ça va devenir l'image michel david
je commence avec vous qui voit résumé le
fait que sur le plan économique pour
beaucoup de grandes différences entre la
cas depuis les libéraux dans ce qu'il
propose en tout cas non mais écoutez à
partir du moment où quatre en fait des
cinq partis ont identifié les méfaits de
l'inflation dans la lutte contre
l'inflation comme la priorité de leur
parti il faut il faut s'attendre à ce
que les mesures se ressentent écoutez
quand on décide de lutter contre
l'inflation ne l'est pas 50 solutions ou
bien on donne de l'argent baron baisse
les impôts les taxes les tarifs en
dehors de ça il n'y a pas grand chose
qu'on peut faire cela étant dit la
coïncidence d'omer troublant la même
journée la même montant et quand madame
angles a dit que monsieur
legault est un copieur je t'en as pas
croire que ça fait bien la faire de
monsieur legault que tout le monde se
ressemble plus qu'à la fin tout le monde
soit mélangé les électeurs savent pas
trop qui promet quoi parce qu'en bout de
ligne si tout le monde est à peu près
égales et que gouvernement et populaire
buy bondit de 10 longueurs continuons
avec legault et la madame en anglais
dont on va voir les images bon comme
vous dites au volant temps là mais comme
vous dites elle a dit ils copient puis
là elle lui a envoyé une carte dont le
sait la mise enceinte des campagnes
temps le voyez l'image cher françois si
tu veux des idées ça me fera plaisir
la même petite boucle rouges peints
boussou répandant vois ça alors là on
joue duo fait judo avec sa d'un côté de
l'eau je vais vous faire entendre avant
d'entendre des laines et christian donc
des échanges aujourd'hui pour rien
on va donner deux mille dollars de
crédits d'impôt remboursables ça veut
dire qu'on paie de l'impôt ou non on va
recevoir le montant de 1000 $
quand le revenu s'élève à moins de 24
mille 195 dollars
après les garderies à 8 et 70 après la
baisse d'impôts après maintenant les
allocations pour les aînés je vous
dirais que françois legault c'est un
copieur puis le plagiat là c'est une
cause de renvoi une chose qui est clair
c'est que le parti de l'économie là
c'est clairement le parti libéral du
québec
alors c'est un peu la question que les
que ces partis veulent envoyé à
l'électorat qui a le meilleur programme
économique la meilleure équipe
économique et hélène du g10 comment vous
voyez ce match depuis deux jours oui
mais en fait c'est pas seulement
l'attaqué peut-être que pil parti
libéral mais c'est un peu tout le monde
parce que oui cette prestation pour les
aînés mais il ya les baisses d'impôt
généralisée que proposent les kakis les
libéraux et les conservateurs
vous avez par exemple les ponctions les
versements dans le fonds des générations
que propose de réduire à tout ou en
partie québec solidaire le pq est aussi
la cac vous avez une taxe de vente aussi
que québec solidaire et les libéraux
veulent diminuer sur certains produits
de base moi ce que samedi je suis
d'accord avec michel là tu sais que tous
les partis politiques ont reçu les mêmes
réponses de leur faut que ce groupe peut
avoir l'élection le coût de la vie est
l'enjeu prioritaire et donc comme le dit
michel n'y a pas trente six mille façons
de répondre à un certain nombre d'outils
seulement ceci dit il ya un an un danger
qui m'apparaît à l'horizon c'est
peut-être un suisse de trop grande
confiance dans la situation économique
du québec les surplus de l'état sont pas
aussi pharaonique que ça c'est comme
conclusive et en plus il faut il faut se
rappeler que une bonne partie de
l'amélioration du bilan du gouvernement
découle de cette inflation que l'on veut
juguler donc ce n'est pas nécessairement
perrin tout cet argent que l'on voit
dans le livre est considéré en plus
qu'il ya toutes sortes de besoins qui se
font encore sentir notamment nos écoles
qui tombent en ruine nos routes qui ne
sont pas réparés ecce terra de se priver
de manière définitive de revenus
importants de l'ethos c'est un pays
quand même risqué à long terme christian
waber traditionnellement au québec on
l'avait en juillet le noël des global
avec le père noël la fée des étoiles
tout le kit là maintenant on va voir le
noël des électeurs en fait on nous a
alors fait et on va voir quatre bernois
parce que comme on le dit la d4 d5
deux parties en fait nous propose des
cadeaux high as juste parce que le
pauvre paul st pierre plamondon qui
osent parler du français est un peu
archaïque mais plus sérieusement moi
j'veux pas économiste mais je suis un
peu troublant parce que là dans une
période de déflation même semble que
commencer a garoché de l'argent dans
l'économie est ce que c'est vraiment
votre on nous dit qu'il va peut-être
avoir une récession au fil d'arrivée le
fonds des générations ensemble ce n'est
pas dans l'esprit du fonds des
générations
que d'utiliser cet argent là en fait
pour baisser les impôts je comprends
qu'on est très s'imposer au québec mais
monsieur legault ces temps ci m'a fait
penser serait pas contente l'oenologie à
justin trudeau est bien apte à wall
quand on avait l'impression que l'argent
n'est pas un problème pour dépenser ont
dépensé au départ c'est que je trouve
que j'espère que le tome c'est par cl ça
va nous coûter cher cette campagne
électorale là ça fait juste quelques
jours que c'est comment s'y faisant
toujours en train de nous offrir des
cadeaux des cadeaux des ça manque un peu
de hauteur je trouve que je suis
tellement pense que cela bon on donne de
l'argent qui peut être contre ça moi
même j'ai vu moi j'ai plus le sentier de
ça je sais ce que je veux est éligible à
leurs cadeaux j'espère qu'on va
prononcer ou autre chose je sais pas
cette campagne de très bien
parti libéral du québec je vous entendre
sur les problèmes de recrutement de
candidats manifestement le désistement
d'un candidat dans un jean talon à
québec qui a forcé une collaboratrice de
management anglade peut-être qu'elle se
trouvait au mauvais endroit au mauvais
moment madame anglais jeudi à bombay
vous allez être parfaite comme candidat
madame anglade s'en défend on va
l'écouter puis je vous entends d'après
dans quelle mesure est ce que vous êtes
confiant d'avoir véritablement 125
candidats confiante d'avoir 125
candidats sans hésiter c'est pas une
candidature spontanée c'est quelque
chose qui était prévu comme j'ai dit
plus tôt à ma candidature devait être
annoncée plus tôt il ya eu des enjeux de
kovy de sur l'autobus donc on a tout
organisé pour partir la campagne et
après ça me lancer dans la course puis
je suis prête chez mes photos sont
prises n'est pas un carton en vienne
puis je vois était sur le terrain de cet
après midi dans jean talon si elle qui
était donc à bord de l'autobus
directrice de la recherche elle a été le
travailler avec monsieur barrette à
l'époque donc c'est quelqu'un qui était
dans les rouages de l'organisation
libérale
celle david sur le début de campagne de
madame anglade c'est difficile c'est
très difficile on a vu dès le lancement
sa valeur d'un lancement un peu
chaotique une mise en scène un peu plus
pauvres si je peux dire mais pour
revenir à ces problèmes de recrutement à
la ils sont gravés et je pense qu'il
révèle un problème encore plus profond
vous savez qu'un attaché politique
devienne candidat il n'y a rien de mal à
ça le soit dans le passé et peut-être ma
voix jean-françois disait ça peut faire
d'excellents candidats mais ça
normalement on n'annonce pas mal
longtemps avant que le clanche mans des
élections ce qui est anormal c'est de
voir pas simplement dans jean talon on a
vu la même chose dans
jean lesage le compte est pas loin à
québec où un autre attaché politique on
était dans le fond on le relance sos
parce que on trouvait pour personne et
c'est ça qui est pas normal comment se
fait il par exemple que dans une
circonscription comme jean talon en
photo un château fort libéral
jusqu'à tout récemment qui est pas au
sein de l'association parce qu'il ya
quand même des militants j'imagine leur
dit si tu es là encore c'est chez les
personnes lèvent la main le président de
l'association est ce assez il avait
prévu de problèmes souvenez vous patrice
et ont commencé à lancer des appels de
candidatures sur internet faut le faire
dès le mois de janvier mais on est rendu
là 3 au troisième jour de la campagne et
encore je suis pas premier de deux
postes à combler alors non le problème
et les plus graves il est au sein de la
de la base du parti là il est plus
visible parce qu on est en campagne
électorale mais hélène et christian
c'est pas ce serait pas l'un vers ce qui
serait étonnant que ça roule comme dans
du beurre que ça est bien qu'il ya plein
de candidats ils sont quand même très
moche et le vote francophone c'est comme
si on leur y en avait le résultat de ce
dont on parle depuis des mois et des
mois des difficultés du parti libéral
hélène à oui voilà c'est la confirmation
de ce que l'on ressent depuis un bon
bout de temps encore une fois je suis
obligé d'être d'accord avec michel dans
des circonscriptions comme jean talon
qui ont déjà été des châteaux forts
habituellement ça donne lieu à des
investitures chaudement confesse-t-il ya
plusieurs personnes qui aspirent à être
le candidat libéral j'ai rien contre le
fait qu'une stratège politique soit
nommée candidate mais ça sonne un peu
comme excusez moi l'expression et avec
respect mais comme un poteau
rappelez-vous en 2011 le npd ici à
ottawa il y en avait des députés des
candidats partout notamment des
personnes qui étaient en voyage à las
vegas et qui ont fini par être élu dans
ces colonnes mais bref le fait d'avoir
des candidats ça ne prouve rien c'est la
qualité des candidats est et quel est le
processus qui est menacée mais moi
j'estime que madame anglade la halle à
sa sortie qui leur fait la semaine
dernière lorsqu'elle a dit je suis le
seul parti qui a voté à la fois pour la
loi 85 contre la loi 96 et la loi va
bien et je voyais ça un peu comme sont
le dernier clou dans son cercueil ça ça
venait sceller confirmé une déconnexion
profond moon avec l'électorat
francophone et je vous parie patrice
qu'après cette élection on voudra
certainement la fête de dominique
anglade parce que c'est ce qu'on fait
maintenant les chefs politiques sont
jetables mais le problème il dépasse
très largement madame anglade ne sais
pas quels faits particulièrement mauvais
travail c'est un problème à long terme
du parti libéral qui se cherche qu il ne
sait plus à qui ils parlent et ceux qui
ne connaissent qu'il défend donc
christian on voit l'aboutissement de ce
dont on parle depuis un an
moi je suis d'accord avec mes deux
collègues surtout que jean talon quel
symbole c'est une vieille forteresse me
rappelle jean claude rivet
jean talon est une tragédie pour le
parti libéral qui quand même le plus
vieux parti politique au québec c'est
l'un des deux parties avec le pq que
fait la révolution tranquille ya
toujours eu en fait un des vecteurs non
francophones qui est une partie de sa
force mais avait toujours un ajout aux
francophones sait ce qu'il a perdu parce
que j'irais même j'aurais pas être
méchant mais moi ça me fascine de voir à
quel point il ya une antipathie chez
beaucoup de francophones à l'égard des
libéraux méchanceté l'égard des libéraux
donc est ce que les libéraux vont
disparaître ont quand même leur faire
savoir non non francophones mais tenant
compte de ce qu'a été le parti berra
n'ont pas le vent dans les voiles c'est
moins que jean talon jantes
bons
échanges aujourd'hui intéressant par
ailleurs entre monsieur le gru et
monsieur duhaime sur la pandémie c'est
sûr que ça allait arriver monsieur
duhaime s'est beaucoup son moteur c'est
cette grogne enfin grosse partie de son
moteur dire ça comme ça c'est cette
grogne anti mesures sanitaires qui s'est
développée région de québec la beauce on
nous dit qu'en mauricie la désespoir on
verra tout cela tout au tout début il
faut entendre les deux hommes puis on
vient
il ya certains leaders qui ont alimenté
une certaine grogne à qui on dit on veut
faire rentrer la grogne à l'assemblée
nationale
je pense que tout le monde doit être
responsable
je trouve particulièrement irresponsable
depuis plusieurs mois c'est qu'on a un
premier ministre que diviser
profondément les québécois comme jamais
dans l'histoire ce premier ministre là
c'est le premier ministre de la division
je ne sais pas comment il peut
conseiller du quai pour la liberté alors
qu'il a été le premier ministre le plus
liberticides de notre histoire jamais un
premier ministre du québec ne bafouent
autant les droits civiques de ses
citoyens une à brimer la liberté du
visuel comme françois legault
alors ça fera partie du débat bien sûr
la même si pour certains c'est oui
christian lésés
cherchent aussi très bon pour éviter un
vide parce que autant durant la gestion
de la pandémie bon il y avait un appui
très large à l'égard du premier ministre
legault s'était pas d'être plus totale
monsieur qui est un conte en fait est un
but stigmatiser on parlait de
complotiste de gens qui n'étaient pas
mais le temps passe et plus beaucoup de
québécois qui quand il repense à ce bain
il trouve cette allée tête un petit peu
loin et et je dis pas que monsieur le
groupe pour l'appui la majorité de la
population la subit une minorité
substantielles sur ce thème là des
libertés sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire qui est susceptible de voter
pour éric duhaime examen réussi quand
même à l'export représente sera même
fort d'avoir réussi à être au même
niveau que les quatre aux deux parties a
ya deux ans c'était rien éric duhaime
puis a été très maîtrisée par l'élite
politico médiatique moi je pensais
vraiment lui il faut surveiller souvent
c'est trop pénible parce qu'ils ont
réservé voir le temps passer beaucoup de
gens que je connais qui appuyait
fermement legault à l'époque midi avec
le recul c'était allé trop loin
michel michel avait 34 jours devant nous
est ce que c'est encore ainsi vivent
cette grogne là selon vous pour que ça
se traduise en ventes dans la vraie
boîte le vrai papier je me suis posé la
question au premier jour quand j'ai vu
que monsieur duhaime ne soulevait même
pas lui-même cette question là au moment
de son lancement il ya pas dit un mot
sur la pandémie les mesures centa c'est
simplement quand on lui a posé une
question que l'oeil a dit bah oui puis
on connaît sa cassette alors j'étais un
peu surpris moi de voir qu'il ya
par ailleurs aujourd'hui que monsieur
legault lui se charge de ramener la
question sur le tapis je comprends qu'on
était en beauce mais super si l'otan
parle pas mal à sa place j'aurais pas
réveiller le lion pudeur mais il ya
quelque chose qui peut-être fatigue
monsieur legault c'est que depuis le
tout début de la pandémie et de la
campagne anti mesure de de monsieur
duhaime jamais le chef conservateur a
voulu répondre à la question suivante
oui mais vous que c'est que vous auriez
fait ça mouraient comme des mouches que
ce que vous auriez fait il répond pas et
ça je pense que ça à challes monsieur
legault qui se dit on peut pas laisser
ce que le ahly dire n'importe quoi sans
qui se commettent sur ce qu'ils auraient
dû faire être fait selon lui et est-ce
que ça l'agacé l'inde selon vous parce
que monsieur legault et etam a été
impliqué lors de cette crise que c'est
sale ça le her d'entendre des choses
comme celles là où parce que électorale
ma salle à gaz
peut-être mais vous savez la ligne elle
est fine entre
contester les menus mesures sanitaires
et avoir une attitude comme le dit
monsieur legault irresponsable je ne dis
pas que monsieur duhaime a toujours
respecté cette fille cette ligne fine là
en particulier lorsqu'il était encore
sur les ondes radiophoniques mais aussi
quelque chose d'un petit peu agaçant je
trouve dans cette façon comme monsieur
legault de dire qu'il n'y avait qu'une
façon de voir les choses le couvre-feu
il ya juste le québec qui on a imposé un
le passeport centa sa peau était partout
tout le monde n'a pas adopté
nécessairement les mêmes mesures dans
les écoles il y avait eu me semble-t-il
il y aurait dû y avoir semble-t-il de
l'espace pour remettre en question
certaines mesures sans pour autant être
considéré comme un complotiste montre
que quelqu'un qui ne reconnaît pas la
validité de cette créance en terre et
donc il ya une espèce de vision
totalitaire que dont se fait porteur
monsieur legault et qui vient alimenter
justement la colère que canalise
monsieur duhaime moi je postulerai que
ces gens qui sont si en colère le sont
beaucoup justement parce qu'ils n'ont
pas trouvé qu'il y avait l'espace de
contestation bien encadrés alors les
deux hommes finalement s'alimente
naulleau dans leur gîte et respectives
[Musique]
oui conclusion peut-être christian parce
que je veux parler du
réseau pas aller trop loin là dedans
parce qu'il peut être emporté un peu pas
par son soupçon d'émotion et les gens en
fait qu'ils sont susceptibles de voter
pour lui c'est pas des gens qui à
l'époque était à ce point là contre les
mesures sévères mais avec le recul il
voit que l'opposition à legault se sent
beaucoup éric duhaime et il trouve comme
je les dis peut-être qu'un italien un
petit peu loin donc une instance comme
dit comme dit hélène in fine qu'il faut
pas dépasser mais c'est pas bon ton
françois legault de trop revenir sur la
crise en terme semble intelligent l'ont
vu aller ils savent que c'était
courageux et amira mieux pas intérêt à
ce qu'on parle trop il est en bas ou
ceux là où je le rappelle monsieur
j'aime espère peut-être faire élire des
candidats beauce-nord bossu dans
chauveau bien sûr à québec chez lui
avoir un petit mot christian sur michael
gorbatchev je disais en d'entrée de jeu
en commençant cette émission qu'il est
de ceux qui a changé le cours des choses
car mais avait-il le choix pas le choix
il ya beaucoup d' analyse à faire mais
il a décidé de tenter de réformer
tellement que tout s'est écroulé on en
est et poutine lui en veut encore qu'est
ce que ça vous inspire vous christian
monsieur gorbatchev
tristement arrive aujourd'hui en plus
avec la guerre en ukraine c'est
intéressant je trouve qu'on doit lui
être très très reconnaissant monsieur
gorbatchev parce que l'urss et un empire
nucléarisé qui s'est effondré donc ça va
plus se faire sans dans la fureur dans
le sang et dans la guerre parce que les
russes perdaient du précieux or ça c'est
fait pacifiquement et gorbatchev 57 face
love de la russie qui était plus ouverte
à l'occident et ça rappelle quelque
chose c'est que quand même une période
après la chute de l'urss où les
vainqueurs les explosions en tout
premier lieu ont manqué de sagesse ils
n'ont pas de traiter correctement la
russie parce que quelques années où la
russie était ouverte à l'occident je
rentrais d'excusés en fait la question
de poutine à l'égard de l'ukraine mais
ça me rappelle ça qu'il ya eu un moment
où là s'ils arrêtent plus plus intégrée
en fait un autre univers bon il est
ensuite les déments vous des vieux
démons russes qui sont revenues mais
l'occident les états unis ont une
responsabilité objective là dessus parce
que et en russie actuellement c'est pas
encore bat chefs qui sont populaires de
saison plus populaires oui ben oui mais
déjà à l'époque en 89 88 89 ça m'avait
fasciné à quel point il était détesté
dans les rues où on faisait des
entrevues et à l'étranger il était déjà
vu comme le père de la perestroïka de la
glace note de l'ouverture qu'elle avait
donc on a couvert ça de loin mais c'est
un personnage qui est extrêmement
important qui est qui tout à fait c'est
un des hommes qui a marqué le xxème
siècle il y arrive des moments où on
doit se demander de quel côté de
l'histoire on veut être et je pense que
monsieur gorbatchev à ce moment-là
choisi le bon côté mais il est à
prétention de l'histoire c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement subjectif alors
autant nous on peut trouver comme on se
le dit que monsieur gamache fo udt de la
vision et je dirais même une vision
humaniste de l'histoire autant je peux
comprendre qu en union soviétique
surtout avec la suite des choses
il y est russe sont nostalgiques
je pense pas que ce soit aux
nostalgiques du communisme pac
nostalgiques de la grotte de la grandeur
de la russie michel